[Philip]: Here's... Here's.... We need a photo op, Anna,
this is very important
[Anna]:This doesn't work!
[Philip]: Here, use mine. Use mine.
[Anna]: Thank you.
(Audience cheers)
Wow! This is beautiful and not gold.
(audience laughs)
I have a speech prepared, guys!
Two drinks in and I'm on medication,
so we'll see how this goes.
First off, I just want to say I am– I am incredibly honored to be here
when Wes and Phil and Dan told me
that they wanted to give me this award.
I thought, wow, you know my years of
friendship with them have finally paid off.
(audience laughs)
Joke success!
Yes, um, I always wanted to be in entertainment.
You know when I was a kid, I told my dad I wanted to be an actor,
so he immediately enrolled me in karate classes.
But, of course, I didn't seriously pursue
my dream until I was an adult
and only because I lost my little sister to suicide.
And I realized that when I died, I wanted to at least know that I had lived doing what I had loved.
Before my sister died, I thought that I was gonna be like a military officer or a veterinarian
because that's the practical route, right? That's a realistic path.
She killed herself when I was 17, and I was a senior in high school and I did not laugh for two years.
Um, it wasn't until I saw a stand-up special on TV that I laughed for the very first time
and the person on my TV was Margaret Cho.
You know, I looked at her on stage and I was like: "Oh hey, you know, maybe I can do that."
It was the very first time I had ever seen an Asian woman do stand up and before that,
the only Asian female face I had ever
seen on TV was of course... Lucy Liu.
Right? That's all we had.
And seven years later... here I am.
(one woo)
Thank you for the one woo, appreciate that.
(Audience cheers)
Thank you.
But it– it is all thanks to seeing that one face on the screen that looked like mine
because I was able to think:
"Oh, she's doing that, maybe I could do that too."
You know I used to think that being Asian gave me an edge in this industry.
You know you would see how hard people worked and you're like: "Oh shit, I could do way better than that."
And hard work equals success, right?
That's what we're taught by our parents,
that if you work hard, success will come.
So I thought that's what must happen with Hollywood.
But last year I booked the lead role
in a feature film with a major studio.
(Audience cheers)
Thank you.
I auditioned, I did callbacks with producers, and I met with the executives of the studio at the company.
We shook hands, they told me:
"Oh, we can't wait to work with you."
"We're so excited that you're the lead of our movie."
And I drove home, like, singing the Katy Perry in my car.
Because this was my dream and I was finally living it and it had actually come true.
You know I could not believe that I wasn't just like a one-line co-star on "Awkward' talking about my small boobs.
Or I wasn't like, a supporting best friend who was like, upset about a B minus.
I was the lead.
A few days later my manager called me while I was on set, directing a short film
and he was very confused.
He was like: "When you met with those executives, are you sure that you booked the lead role?"
And I was like: "Well yeah, we were talking about the lead character,"
"We mentioned it by name,
I had auditioned with that dialogue."
"Why?"
And he said that they'd gotten the
official paperwork in for the offer,
and what I was being given
was the role of the best friend.
The lead was going instead to a white woman.
And we sat in silence for a bit and then,
finally, I asked him very quietly,
I said: "Is it because I'm Asian?"
And he didn't say anything for a hot minute,
but then he said:
"Honestly? You know, that's what I'm thinking."
"I mean what else could it be? What could
have changed in those couple of days?"
That was the very first time in my career that I realized that the color of my skin,
might actually stand in the way of me and my dream.
You know we hear stories of racism in Hollywood all the time.
We've encountered racism in our real life,
we're not fucking idiots.
Sorry, there's children here.
But somehow, this was– this was so different because it had never mattered before
you know I thought: "Oh if you work hard enough, you can achieve your dreams. If you work hard enough,"
"and hone your craft enough, and are talented enough, how can a Hollywood ignore you?"
And to me it felt crazy. 'Cause it was like, I thought this lead role was the success
after seven years of performing stand-up,
and being in improv and acting classes,
and writing and editing and producing
and directing and creating short films
and web series and weekly content,
and building a following and hosting a podcast,
and running a clothing line,
and audition, and hustling,
and just working fucking hard.
(Audience cheers)
Thank you.
I would like to mention, just for clarity,
I was Asian the whole time.
(Audience laughs)
In the audition room, in the callback,
in the meeting with the producers.
'Cause for two seconds I was freaking out, I was like:
"Did I wear foundation that was like, way too light for my skin?"
But the studio would not budge.
I was either the best friend or I was out.
So I was out.
Then, there was Emma Stone in "Aloha," there was Scarlett Johansson in "Ghost in the Shell,"
there was Tilda Swinton,
and Kimmy Schmidt season 2 episode 3,
the giant middle finger to the Asian community by calling us: Respectful Asian Portrayals in Entertainment
aka RAPE.
What the fuck?
How is this still happening? But more importantly:
How can we change it?
You know, Phil had a 17 minute video
about whitewashing in Hollywood,
and it was great.
And the one thing I took away from it that I thought he– he put so perfectly was that it starts with us.
You know? Not demanding to be included
but creating our own space in this world.
To encourage our peers to be writers and actors and directors and producers
and creators, instead of letting our parents convince us that we should be doctors and lawyers and scientists.
We all need to be someone's Margaret Cho.
Because the only way we will be heard,
is if enough of our voices speak out.
Thank you.
(Applause and cheers)